I've previously made videos on things
that I no longer own or buy but I've
realized that there are some things that
I just hate to spend my money on or
things that I just never really see
myself buying and oddly there's also
things that I spend more money on after
having embraced a minimalist lifestyle
this will be a two-part video so be sure
to subscribe and hit the notification
Bell so you won't miss when I post the
next video where I'll be sharing 10
things that I spend more money on as a
minimalist but today I'm going to be
sharing with you the 10 things that I
just refus to spend money on before we
begin hey I'm Jessie on this channel we
talk about minimalism and intentional
living through a holistic lens as in we
don't just talk about decluttering and
making a Space cozy as a previous
hospice nurse I like to go further than
superficial conversations but I also
want to warn you that this video is
meant as a list of ideas that are
personal to me I know that when I was
first starting with minimalism and
trying to not only declutter physical
items but also negative spending habits
these sort of videos were really helpful
to me so hopefully it will be helpful to
you but this by no means is a list of
things that you should or shouldn't be
doing first up is themed party decor
whether the party is for an adult or for
children themed party decor is just not
something that we spend money on or
actually just really party decor in
general I see for example kids parties
kids parties especially I'm like why why
why even buy decorations they don't care
kids are just running around doing their
own thing if you spent that money on
like a bouncy house for example or games
or a pinata kids will be much happier
but I've seen arches of balloons at
certain parties for kids and I'm
thinking poor kiddos because they're
just staring at this balloon arch
wishing that they could just play with
the darn things instead of looking at
them and even if it's not a kids party
that we're talking about and it's an
adult party the people that are there to
see you to spend time with you they
really aren't going to notice those
things and if they are and they're going
to point it out like oh this is Bland
you don't have a tablecloth they may not
have the best intentions anyway I don't
really know that you'd want those kinds
of people at your parties and even if I
did have like an extra budget I still
think that a pinata or a bouncy house or
even if it's for adults like spending
that money towards better food for
example that's where I would rather put
my money towards not the decor that
nobody's really caring about anyway
number two is something that I feel very
strongly about but please don't hate me
for this one it's unnecessary work
attire or office Decor or just any
expenses that are related to work I'm of
the belief that whenever we go to work
we're going there to make money I'm not
going there to spend more money because
the more money that I spend on things
that are related to work then the longer
that I have to to be there and work in
exchange for that stuff I worked as a
nurse for almost a decade and in that
time I replaced my scrubs really only
whenever I changed units for work or
actually also when I was pregnant
because things just didn't fit anymore
and I remember having a pair of Scrubs
that I had leaned on some paint and it
had paint stains one of them was like
tearing apart cuz I tried to wear it
when I was pregnant cuz I refused to buy
more scrubs and then it was kind of like
a little bit torn and I still ended up
wearing it after I was pregnant my
goodness like my scrubs were looking
raggedy and not very good and I probably
should have purchased more but it felt
to me like why why should I spend my
money on this I'm coming here to make
money and you want me to spend more
money on these things and some people
would buy them with like the different
patterns and make them pretty I didn't
care like I was there to get my job done
and to do my job well and then when it
comes to office decor and things like
that I know that for example my sister
who works at an office loves to kind of
decorate a little bit so that it feels a
little bit more cozy and it kind of
becomes like a home away from home but
me personally again I just find it like
if I'm spending more money on these
things then that means that I have to be
there longer and that's just not my
priority so take it or leave it that was
something that I just have always felt
strongly about and even things like
Gatherings like work gatherings I never
ever presented if it was something where
I had to pay money to go to like for
example some of my co-workers would
sometimes gather at restaurants and
things like that I never would do that
and if there was a meeting where there
was free food I would be there but if I
had to pay I just no I was never there
to me work was just very clearly defined
as work and home was very separate and I
never really mixed the two and that was
how I was able to really keep peace
especially being a nurse uh ICU hospice
like dealing with very emotional type
things I just I wanted to have a very
clearly defined separate line work and
home and I never really wanted to
combine them together or make work feel
more cozy so that I'd spend more time
there just no no work is work and home
is home and uh spending any more money
on work to me was just not worth it
number three is the alexas the Googles
and all the other thingamajiggy that are
out there this is not something that I
wouldn't use like if I was gifted it for
example but it's something that I
personally wouldn't spend my money on
and I'm not bashing your smart Tech with
this because I do have Smart Tech like I
have a smart thermostat and I have Smart
bulbs and they're very helpful but I've
just realized the things that they do to
me I'll give you an example here
recently I caught myself out loud saying
the words I cannot not have a microwave
and I knew when I said that I had to
take a break so I took 30 months off or
not 30 months 30 days of not using a
microwave and it really opened my eyes
to making me see how lazy I had become
how dependent on technology I had become
and how ungrateful I had become I
remember once reading this book about
the science of money and I don't
remember the title so I'll look it up
and see if I can put it down here or put
it in the description but it basically
said that you shouldn't talk about your
time when you were in poverty or the
time when money was tight because it
keeps you in that y mindset and I
disagree I disagree because I feel that
when I remember that I came from poverty
when I remember that I had one shirt to
wear when I remember that I had to share
a meal with my family it keeps me more
humble and it can be so easy to really
become dependent on technology and I
have a lot of Technology obviously I
have this YouTube channel so I think for
me the less I have of it the less
dependent I can become and I just I know
at least for me I become so easily
dependent on it where sometimes I'll be
laying down and I want to tell ser to
turn the thermostat and I realize my
phone's not there I'm like uh I have to
walk to the thermostat and then I just
kind of look at myself like yesie what a
spoiled brat You' become it's something
that can be really really helpful like
especially somebody that has a physical
disability man how awesome it is that we
have Smart Tech but for me personally I
just know that I easily become lazy and
dependent and ungrateful so spending the
money on these sorts of things is not
something that I would personally do not
that it's not awesome not that they're
not helpful but it's just something that
I don't want to even more dependent on
number four is car washes some of you
will think that I am gross for saying
this and some of you will relate to me I
recently sold my car after quitting my
nursing job and I tell you I had that
car for years and I washed it twice once
because I parked under a tree where a
bunch of birds or maybe one bird with
diarrhea pooped all over my car and then
the other time was because I drove
through this very muddy area and it
wasn't going to rain anytime soon and I
didn't want my car getting crusty so
those were the only two times that I
ever washed my car I know that that my
husband completely disagrees with me on
this he thinks that if the car is what's
getting you to work and it's what's
bringing home the bacon then you should
take care of your car but to me it just
seems like a superficial exterior thing
that doesn't really impact how the car
functions so I never really cared for
car washes we don't have a garage so the
rain just kind of does it by itself and
it's totally free and I don't have to
spend time on that so I don't know for
me car washes are just something that I
never could quite understand let me know
where you fall in this one are you for
car washing or do you just totally hate
it like me let me know in the comments
number five dry cleaning and laundry
services one of the very first things to
leave my outrageously overstuffed
Wardrobe when I was first decluttering
was all of my dry clean only items and
then I was thereafter very careful not
to repurchase dry clean items every now
and then I would accidentally bring
something home and realize oh shoot it
was dry clean and then I'd have to
return it but ever since then I have
never intentionally bought dry clean
items one obviously because they cost
money to take care of but then two
because I just don't want to bother the
time to take them from there and bring
them back and then I also know that
because I have to have that extra hassle
it's likely not even something that I'm
going to wear that often because I don't
want to bother with it I don't even own
an iron I don't even buy clothing that
requires ironing for that matter because
I don't want to bother with that I I
don't want to spend my precious lifespan
doing laundry in very particular ways I
mean I don't know maybe you enjoy
laundry but for me when it comes to
laundry and clothing I prefer the bare
necessities the simpler the better
number six is food and drink at
amusement parks fairs or festivals you
might think that I'm a total cheap skape
by now but I'm really not it's just that
I can value spending money in certain
areas but there's other areas where I
just can't justify it and this is one of
those areas that $7 slice of pizza that
tastes like a piece of cardboard to me
is just not worth it I recently took my
kids to a couple of different festivals
and instead of buying that overpriced
food we spent that money towards them
playing at a bouncy house for half an
hour and they had a blast to me the
experience of a fair or a festival or an
amusement park it's about the experience
of being there not the food that I eat
while I'm there number seven is a simple
one and it's unnecessary bills or just
an additional quantity of bills so
obviously we all want to reduce our
bills and cut back on certain things and
when I did quit my job I did quit a lot
of our bills like for example I sold my
car so that meant that I didn't have oil
changes anymore that I wouldn't have
maintenance anymore that I wouldn't have
to pay the tag fee anymore so that
eliminated a lot of expenses I also did
a lot of other things that really remove
some expenses and I have a different
video on that I I'll I'll link it down
below but one of the things that I did
too was just to kind of condense our
expenses so for example our insurances I
condensed it down to one company that
would have all of our insurances
together because we also have a business
so we have business insurance and we
were doing separate bills and even
though I have a lot of things automated
to me it just it still takes a mind
space it's easier if I have less bills
to manage and even recently with our
internet company for example I found
that they also have a phone service so I
condensed down our internet and our
phone to one company and that one bill
was actually a lot cheaper so we saved
like $60 off of our phone bill and then
we also had a discount off of our
internet because we merged them together
so being able to merge my bills and to
reduce the quantity of them to me just
saves me a lot of time and energy number
eight is warranties with one exception
my husband recently got an Apple phone
and we purchased the Apple care for a
short term while he received his screen
protector and his phone case from Amazon
which was much much much cheaper and
then we canceled it thereafter but other
than that we just I can't even think of
anything that I have a warranty on and
this is probably something that would
bite me in the butt like for example I
had my computer break unexpectedly I'm
like why where did it even happen like I
never even knocked it I never bumped
into it but things happen so I did have
to replace that and it was quite an
expensive expense but I find that things
rarely happen like that and I find that
if I buy better quality stuff I don't
never have to worry about that stuff
like there's so many kinds of warranties
that people will buy sell you for so
many things that I just I feel like if
you go down that rabbit hole like
there's so much money draining that can
happen so that's just not something that
I personally spend money on number nine
is something that's very important to me
and it's paid Personal Care in the past
I learned how to do individual lash
extensions so I was able to do that I
don't do that anymore I was also able to
do my own Nails I had like this UV thing
and I would do my own nails and put my
little stickers on I don't even do that
anymore so that's that easy done uh but
I also still do things like doing my own
eyebrows cutting my own hair and just to
me Personal Care is not an area where I
want to spend money in I have had uh
times where people will treat me like
for Mother's Day to get my nails done
and I love it and I really enjoy it and
it's a it's a good time and I like the
way that they look for that short time
but it's not something that I can
personally justify spending that money
on I would much much much rather spend
that money on something that's a bigger
purchase that's going to last me for a
while longer I gave an example in a
different video where I had always
thought that posos were for rich people
and that I could never have one and then
I stopped spending on personal care and
I kind of would slowly raise some money
to be able to spend towards me and
something that I would want for myself
and the piano was one of those things
that I wanted to purchase and I'm so
glad that I did I'm so glad that I spent
that money on it I've been playing it
for a few months now and I'm still I'm
still definitely a baby but I've so
enjoyed it certain things that I want
for myself I wouldn't be able to have if
I constantly spend money on certain
things and this is an area where to me I
just can't justify because I can do it
myself and I don't want to spend the
time to drive there and back and wait in
line and make an appointment or all
these things and two the less of it that
I do like for example I don't do my
eyelashes anymore I don't do my nails
anymore the easier it is I feel that I'm
a lot Freer because of that I can just
be me and not have to worry about how am
I looking And I still do definitely
enjoy makeup for example but it's not
something that I'm like obsessed about
like I used to be in the past number 10
is is ice cream and fast food Dairy
flares up my Eczema and makes me feel
bloated and icky and it just is highly
processed and has tons of sugar and it's
much more expensive than if I were to
just buy a bunch of ingredients and make
it at home in a much healthier version I
find that in the summertime my husband
is always wanting to go to the ice cream
parlor but we are very blessed to have a
Vitamix which is able to make ice cream
it's actually made with that purpose
that you can make ice cream with it and
I would often be like why are we
spending all this money on ice cream
that's not even good for us that we're
going to feel icky after having eaten
that I literally could have bought like
bags of fruit and made ice cream at home
so in the summertime we now make our own
ice cream and I basically just buy a
bunch of fruit whenever it's on sale I
freeze it and then make our own and then
when it comes to fast food I just no
longer spend money on that because it's
something that I don't want to spend my
money on something that's going to make
me feel icky afterwards I'd rather spend
it towards good quality ingredients that
make me feel better I actually went as
far too as not even accepting like the
freebies cuz I had an app for a gas
station that would give me free pizzas
and gas station snacks I if I found that
even with those I would feel like why am
I accepting this even though it's free
it's still something that's hurting me
in the long run like it's free now but
eventually I'll have to pay it back with
Dr bills because I'm not healthy because
I'm eating this all the time just
because it's free so so that's just me I
I do still eat those things if that's
what you've got and I'm there at your
house and all you got is pizza that's
fine I'll I'll eat that but it's not
something that I'm going to spend my
money on or that go out of my way to to
look for I would definitely rather to
make my own things at home even if it
takes a little bit longer like even with
the ice cream thing it takes me less
than five minutes to make an ice cream
at home but the time that we would have
spent going and driving to and waiting
in line and getting that ice cream it's
not something that I want to spend money
on okay and this is totally more than 10
but we'll call it a bonus I just can't
not mention this one and it's disposable
items I am not saying that I don't have
disposable items because sometimes
they're necessary but when ever possible
I buy the reusable version there's a lot
of different items around the home that
I've swapped out that disposable version
for the reusable one again it's not just
about the money it's about the time now
I have to go and spend time to be able
to replace these items over and over and
over again so wherever it is possible
that I can kind of ease that not only
the money outflow but also the time and
energy to replace items to me it just
makes things a lot easier where it's a
lot less that I have to think about and
two I also do have two separate videos
of disposable items that you can swap
out for the reusable version so I can
link that down below so you can check it
out after this one that's it for today's
video I hope it didn't come off as me
telling you like this is how you should
do things cuz that was not at all the
intent of the video but I really hope
that you got some value out of it
because some of these I think really
most of these are things that by cutting
out I've not only been able to cut out
an expense but also be able to free up
more time and energy for things that I
do value so hopefully you found it
helpful if so be sure to give it a
thumbs up and subscribe so you won't
miss when I post a new video thank you
so much for watching and I'll see you in
the next one bye for now